In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, from May 17th, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostles
Andronicus and Junior of the Seventy.
On the 17th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostles Andronicus and Junior.
Mentioned by Saint Paul in the Epistle to the Romans, referring to them as his Kinsfolk
and praising them as illustrious among the Apostles, Saint Andronicus and his wife, Junior,
Jews by birth, were converted to Christianity in Jerusalem.
They later became disciples of, and fellow workers with, the Apostle to the nations, and
suffered captivity with him.
Dead to the world and its corruptible lures, they turned their fleshly union into a spiritual
bond that turned them to all men in order to communicate to them the fervor of their
love of God.
They thus brought many pagans to the faith, destroying the temples of idol worship and healing
the sick by the power of the Holy Spirit.
In about the year 58, they were arrested and taken to Rome, where it appears that they
suffered martyrdom, thus gaining crowns of incorruptible glory.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.